-Hey, Matt!
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey. I just wanted to stop
and say hello before the show.
-Ah, nice.
-Actually, you know what?
I heard a little "Friends"
trivia the other day
I thought was
pretty interesting.
-Really? What was it?
-Well, you would know,
so I don't wanna...
-Ah, come on. It'll be fun.
-Um, okay.
How many times do they clap
in the "Friends" theme song?
-Ooh. Uh...five.
-Oh. No. It's actually four.
-What? No.
-Yeah.
-It's five. I've heard it
like a thousand times.
-Yeah, well, no,
it's actually four.
-It's five.
-[ Chuckles ] It's four.
♪♪ So no one told you life was
gonna be this way ♪♪
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap ]
-♪♪ ...was gonna be this way ♪♪
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap ]
-It's five.
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap ]
-♪♪ ...this way ♪♪
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap ]
-♪♪ Gonna be this way ♪♪
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap ]
[ Clap, clap, clap, clap ]
-It's five.
-Four!
[ Rapid clapping ]
-Ohh!
You know what? It is four.
[ Laughs ]
-Told ya. See you out there.
-Yeah, see you out there, man.
[ Laughs ]
It's four. All these years.